No, I followed you like when you were at your peak.
So...
Oh!
Ow!
Okay, you know what?
You can just...
You can just take the attitude...
.
Ow!
I guess I'm washed up, Jack.
I mean, how many years ago it was...
I guess I'm washed.
Washed up.
I mean, it was one clean.
One click.
Alright, alright.
How about...
How about you follow me first and I'll give you your shoutout.
It's just that easy.
Because that's the thing.
He's the issue, right?
He's the issue.
Whether Fuzzy gets the shoutout or not doesn't benefit me at all.
Yeah, but you clearly want to do this for your chatter.
You clearly... because it's day two and you're still on about this Fuzzy guy.
You could have moved on after day one.
Yeah, but I don't think he can move on.
That's the issue.
Yeah, so if you really like your chatter, if you really appreciate them, follow me on Twitter right now.
Fuzzy, Fuzzy, are you in my chat still?
How much...
Or Fuzzy, ditch that guy and come to my chat.
I'll appreciate you.
Fuzzy, Fuzzy, you're fucking Fuzzy!
Fuzzy sucks!
Fuzzy, if you come to my chat, I'll give you a shoutout and I won't even... only on my stream.
Yeah, no, he just said, I'm in Doki's chat right now.
Yeah.
Oh, shit, yeah, and your guy was like, I'm the Sonic chatter too.
Oh, man, your fans coming to me now.
I don't need that follow.
I got Fuzzy already.
Take him, take him.
You don't need him?
Alright!
That's why you got ninthplace.com to break your Fuzzy.
Other viewers in Sonic chat, I would appreciate you.
I would follow somebody to give you that shoutout.
But apparently Sonic doesn't care.
Sonic doesn't care at all.
It's literally one click!
That's right!
The offer's gonna go.
Alright, if you don't do that follow, you'll never get that shoutout or Sonic or Fuzzy back.
Fuzzy, you're gonna have to beg me for this.
You're gonna have to beg me for this, because there's no incentive.
The fact that you can't even do one click, says a lot.
Yeah.
Fuzzy, I didn't mean it.
I'm sorry.
Fuzzy, you don't have to beg in my chat.
Listen, listen, Doki, I can tell we're both stubborn people, so how about this?
Alright, yeah?
How about this?
I don't follow you.
Yeah?
But...
But?
You shout out Fuzzy anyway.
Alright, goodbye.
Fuzzy's my chatter now.
You know what?
Take him.
Fuzzy, you're gonna have her.
I'm not here.
I won't do the run that you made then.
Listen, if there's a chance in this next mini-game where I can save your life and, you know, we can both, you know, survive and thrive together, okay?
I'm clicking the eject button and I'm gonna watch you perish.
Okay?
I'm gonna watch you perish.
I'm gonna be... I'm gonna be...
All I'm saying is that I have the support of my fans.
I don't know about you.
I'm gonna be clasping my hands together.
Okay?
I guess you fall to your demise.
Feels like you're projecting Sonic.
Maybe I am, okay?
Is that such a bad thing?
Oh shit!
Fuzzy, thanks for the sub, Fuzzy!
Oh my god!
Fuzzy, you're not a real one.
You're not the real one.
You won't do stuff for your homies.
I'm not real at all.
Alright, hey guys.
So like...
Yeah, like...
That came out of nowhere.
I was literally eating and then Sonic just came over.
It was like, hey.
And I was like, hey.
While I was trying to eat.
I was really trying to speedrun my fucking lunch.
During the waiting room.
Alright.
I only have my half finished fucking meal in front of me.
The content came to me.
SonicFox jumpscare.
I was like, oh shit, okay.
I guess it's content time.
Hello everybody.
Welcome to day two.
You know like, okay, you know what's funny?
After day one, I was like, oh my gosh, why did I...
I was like, oh my god.
I could have been eliminated and just chilled.
And like, I told my friends and my friends were like, bro, you could have like...
Why did you do this to yourself?
And I was like, but I just wanted to win.
Yeah, my fault.
I just wanted to survive.
My fault.
And then, yeah, and then my friends were like, you're so stupid.
So, I guess I'll be here for day two.
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna get eliminated on day two though.
Oh my gosh, but my exposure!
My free exposure, chat!
For the 1k?
Bro, 1k I need to survive for like two more days, guys.
Like...
This lobby is like 90% Minecrafters.
There is no way any of us are gonna...
Any of the normies out here that don't play Minecraft are gonna survive to day three and four.
Oh my god.
Anyway, so yeah, welcome to day two of the Minecraft Twitch Rivals, the haunted house.
I think the next... this game, this game that we're gonna be doing is like we're supposed to like dodge the monsters or something.
And like run from them and avoid them.
So, that's basically it.
I don't know the... let me know the cinematics.
By the way, there's no emote mode today.
Yeah, apparently you don't have to.
Like monsters are gonna be chasing us.
Like we have to cross some zones.
And then we have to... we have to cross some zones and...
Get to the monsters and like get... avoid the monsters and stuff to the safe zone.
What else do I want to say?
Oh yeah, there's no emote mode this time.
Because there's nothing to ghost at the moment.
So, there's no emote mode.
So, you guys can like backseat me for...
You know, if there was...
If there was no emote mode in the very first game, I would have known about the tech.
You guys would have yelled at me about this.
The jump tech, guys.
You guys would have done... yelled at me about this.
Anyway, is Fuzzy still in my chat?
Fuzzy?
Oh wait, I hear Gloomy.
Gloomy!
Hi!
Doki, I was looking for you earlier and I found you but you were AFK.
Wait, oh yeah, yeah.
Now I'm not... I was eating.
Wait, why is there a ghost here?
What's she doing here?
I don't know, I'm following her.
Doki, you can rest people in the next game.
Oh, okay, okay.
We gotta stick together.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like Infants Legends.
Okay, okay, okay.
We gotta stick together.
Hear my voice.
Well...
Yeah.
Don't... I'll be screaming.
Don't worry if I die.
I'm gonna stick with Antfrost and you can stick with me with Antfrost.
Oh, okay, okay.
And then Antfrost will carry both of us.
Yeah.
Yeah?
Yeah, because he's so strong.
Yeah, you're so... Oh my god, Antfrost, have you been working out?
Yeah.
Antfrost, wow!
Wow!
Oh my god!
Have you been working out?
Yeah.
Has anyone ever told you that you might be the best Minecraft player in the server?
Yes, thank you, Charlie.
You're my best friend.
Okay, I'm not even disgusting.
Me too, me too, me too, me too, me too, me too.
I'm just like, I don't know.
Me puppy, me puppy.
Cursing on accident.
It's okay, as long as like... as long as we... I think it only matters if you're in the finals.
Alright, you've been going around the world.
I've been going around the world.
Yeah, I don't think so either.
I think they just added that for fun.
Where the fuck?
Where were all the urchins?
I think you are.
I think you're gonna make it.
You're gonna be fine.
I was like, what?
Are we still following the ghost?
Guys, I don't think the ghost leads anywhere, guys.
No, no.
Guys, there's so many people.
I'm getting overwhelmed.
Oh my god!
Please!
Okay, I'm gonna find a corner to hide.
There's two people.
Too many voices!
Voices, do you hear all those voices?
There's too many voices!
What do they say?
Alright, I'm gonna eat my lunch, by the way.
I was speedrunning the convention crowd.
No man.
Oh my god, but yeah, I can't believe it.
The... the... what's the word?
My will to win overpowered my rational thinking.
Because I was just like...
You know, I was like, oh my god, I made it to the next day!
And then like, 30 minutes later, the realization came in.
I was like, oh my god, I made it to the next day.
Hey!
Where's your allies?
I think I got this one.
Yeah, oh, you need an ally, don't you, Erob?
I apparently know where three more are.
Oh, you desperate now?
I mean, we were both friends in Mendoza, so I think it's...
We're like, allies today.
Oh yeah, yeah?
You wanna be allied with a VTuber?
Is that where you're at in your life now?
I have nothing against VTubers.
Yeah, you have nothing against VTubers?
Is that what your chat's saying too?
My chat does not represent me.
Oh, it doesn't represent you.
Oh, so you're saying your chat's liars then?
My chat does not reflect me.
Oh, I see, I see.
Well, you know like this game, you can res people, right?
The next game?
Yeah, so I got you, you got me.
Yeah!
Right?
Hey!
I know E-Rob's desperate for allies.
Cuz all his allies are dead.
Oh, my stamina's on cooldown?
Okay, we've got five- Oh, Gumi Gumi's here.
Alright.
Here we go.
Yeah, all his allies died, did not make it.
Alright.
Yeah, we have stamina now.
Yeah, apparently like- oh my gosh, my fucking food.
I can't even eat my food!
God damn it!
Alright, we have voice chat reconnecting in three minutes.
Oh no, I lost her.
I looked away to put my food away!
Alright.
Yeah, I know E-Rob's desperate now.
He needs- he needs people.
Wait, I lost her.
Guys!
Where did Gumi go?
Look, I will carry E-Rob, Gumi will carry me, and then- and Frost will carry Gumi.
We'll have like a chain.
We'll have- we'll have a chain of people helping.
Where the fuck did Gumi go?
Oh, guys, guys, it's time to find Where's Gumi?
Our favorite game.
Where- oh, there- there she is.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright, the chain will start.
The circle.
Alright, so like apparently you can rez people.
And all we need to do is make sure we don't fucking die.
Or if we do die, that- that we're close to- we're close to our allies.
Okay, let's see, let me- I feel like I should adjust the volume a little bit.
I'll put it at 90 because some of the- the volume is so fucking loud sometimes.
But also like, let me double check if...
Uh...
That bring up the game volume.
Okay.
My sound guy says bring up the game volume.
Wait, there's like more stuff now.
I guess I'll bring up the music and the environment.
Okay, I don't know if that's better.
Alright, let's go!
Also, for all the new viewers here!
Uh, I usually stream on the YouTube, so please check me out over there.
Uh, I do like the Twitch events.
The Twitch events I stream on Twitch because, you know...
Makes sense, they- Twitch invites- WHOA!
Okay.
The voices came back, chat.
Oh, sorry, I misread my sound guy.
He said bring it down, I brought it back up.
There we go.
Alright.
The voices came back, I got him.
We'll unmute when the voices start slowing down.
We'll fix that later.
There's just way too many- Too many people are still alive!
Too many people are still alive for this to work.
Okay.
The voices...
They're so loud.
There's like...
There's like music playing!
What the fuck?
Oh my god, took my meds and the voices are still coming!
Oh my god, this is purgatory.
We will- We will re-enable it when the gate round starts.
I don't think- I don't think I can deal with the voices at the moment.
Okay.
So, the voices would- Guys, I forgot to take my meds.
Wait, no, I took my meds, guys.
Guys, it's working!
The meds are working!
The voices stopped!
Oh my god!
The voices- I told you!
Medicine works!
Oh god, your rob came back.
Don't worry, I'll- Make sure I'll keep taking my meds.
Alright.
We're gonna have to- We're gonna have to work together, guys.
This is a teamwork.
Your rob found us.
We're gonna have to work- Oh!
Monsters and prey.
What's this?
Hello again.
The House of Nightmare commends you for surviving the Conjurer's first two tests.
I did it!
It is now time to resume your challenged nightmares.
You will find yourselves in the basement.
In the basement?
Homes of many of our ferocious monsters and ghouls.
What the fuck?
You may escape via any elevator at the far end of the complex.
But, they can hold only 100 of you.
We have to get to their- To get to the elevators, you must proceed through two safe zones- Wait, that means eight people are gonna get in the elevator?
Eliminated.
That protect you from the monsters.
Wait, what protects me?
The third and final safe zone is the elevator.
Move quickly, because the last few people to reach the safe zone will not survive this nightmare.
Oh shit.
In total, ten of you will surrender yourselves to the House forever.
Oh shit, ten of us?
Guys, that's gonna be me.
Wait, what happens?
You will be injured and unable to move at a normal speed.
Oh, so I have to make sure I don't- If they are feeling- There's parkour?
Other players can heal you by crouching next to you, speeding up your recovery.
Oh no, there's parkour.
But this is not a time to rely on others, because it's everyone- Oh no, not platforming.
Each of you will have a stamina meter.
It will decrease as you sprint.
And if it hits zero, you will- You will lose the ability to sprint for three seconds.
It was a good run, guys.
It was!
Guys, it was a good run.
Now we have platforming.
Do your best to arrive in the safe zone as quickly as possible.
It was a good run.
If the gate closes before you arrive, you'll be ours forever.
The parkour is not that- Yeah, okay, for a normal person.
Guys, I already have the VTuber debuff.
I don't know what you want from me.
Guys, I learned the jump tech.
Oh my god, there's Kachow!
I learned the jump tech, like, after the game was over.
Okay.
Let's see.
Where is- Okay, we need to find- Wait, where's Gumi?
Where's Gumi?
Where is she?
I need her to res me when I get hit.
I need her to res me.
I need to be on her backpack.
Where's the backpack?
Where's- That is not very helpful, guys.
That is- Where the f- I don't know where- Oh, there's Gumi.
That's her.
Wait, is that her?
Is that- Yeah!
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We all stick together, yes?
Don't worry.
We stick together.
I'll save you if you save me.
Of course!
Wait, who's our group?
Who else do we get?
People that are coming over here.
We're meeting here.
Whoever's here is in our group.
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah, we're all gonna help each other out, right?
Warren, come here!
You wanna join our group?
Alright, guys.
Who's in this group?
All my friends.
Like, the cool people?
And if you're my friend, you would join.
All my friends.
So, Gumi?
Is that all your friends, Gumi?
Ooh, that's tough.
That's tough.
This is it?
This is everyone?
Well, not except for this guy.
This is it?
This guy's not our friend.
That's crazy.
Oh!
Except for that one guy over there.
So many friends.
That's all.
I wish I had this many friends.
I wish you two.
Hey, I wish you two, man.
I'm helping him out.
I don't care who.
We need to get everybody through this.
Oh, you think so?
Yeah, totally me too.
Well, not everybody.
Because you can heal each other.
I'm saving everybody, Brad.
I think we need to stay near the beginning, but don't stay too close to the beginning.
Oh, so you wanna like...
Like the front.
So you wanna stutter.
Like get to the other side a little.
Yeah, let the people in the front kinda act like meat shields.
Oh, like the aggro.
They're all gonna be like...
They're all gonna be like all the mobs.
Yeah.
They're gonna die and they're gonna be like crying.
Save us!
Save me!
And then Matt's just gonna run past them.
They cried out, save us, and I said no.
Okay, buddy.
You can save Goomy.
There's no way back to playing games.
Wait, where's Ad?
Bye, Goomy.
I thought Ad was supposed to help us.
I'll miss you, Goomy.
Ad keeps gathering people.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I'll stop.
I thought Ad was gonna betray us there.
No, he would never.
I know where he lives.
Yeah, where?
I'll keep it a secret.
I'm trying to hear you.
Me and my chat will keep it a secret.
2279 Acacia Street.
Oh, oh.
Okay.
Oh, no.
I'm gonna go.
How am I supposed to win if we don't know his address?
Oh my god, two minutes.
Has it been eight minutes already?
Wait, really?
Damn.
All right, Goomy, you wouldn't let me die, right?
We'll advance to day three together, right?
All I'm saying, Goomy, is for the fourth game, if we combine our chat's IQs together to do the puzzle, we might be able to beat one puzzle.
We might be able to solve one puzzle.
We might be able to solve one puzzle together.
Did you hear the lyrics?
Okay, let's go look for our friends.
Hey, hey, hey.
Oh my god, everybody's talking.
I found one.
All right.
Wait, Bad Boy Halo is gonna help us?
Oh, I found them.
Oh, is that the group?
Yeah.
But it's like bobbing like crazy.
I don't like to...
You abandoned us.
I was scared.
You're gonna make sure we live right at...
Are they gonna find you?
We gotta stick together.
Yeah.
Okay, so Bad wants to stutter, like to get to the other side tunnel too.
He wants to wait to leave a little.
I don't know about that either.
He said he wants to use people as meat shields, but I think the monster's reset.
They probably say in areas.
Yeah, maybe they're saying that so that he's gonna make us slow down and he's gonna be in the front.
Okay, why don't we all leave on the right hand side?
Why don't we all leave through the right hand side of the gate?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I like that.
That's a good idea.
And Rob's going to the right.
Okay, so...
Yeah, you can heal each other.
Okay.
Stick to the right body.
Oh, one more minute.
One more minute.
Wait, Shani, can't we like build that?
Yeah, exactly.
I'm scared.
Exactly.
Oh my god.
There's no way they're gonna let us die.
Right?
Okay, revive me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, revive me too.
Well, we come as a couple, Dio.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're like a package two for one.
A two for one Dio.
Oh my god.
There's so many of them.
There's so many people.
I'm using the stamina thing.
I know, Fuzz.
Let's go over here.
Are you sprinting?
I'm sorry.
Okay, I'm coming over here.
Wait, you can...
Like hit W and then jump and then go W.
What?
Just like hit W and then jump and then like go W.
And then sort of like jump along like this.
And then like...
Ah, sweet.
I understand what you mean.
I'm confused.
Okay, let's go.
Go stand on the right side.
I'm confused.
Are we sprinting?
We got this!
Oh!
Here we go!
The last one!
Gina!
Where... where... where's my team?
Guys, turn off the music, please.
It's so annoying.
Where's my team?
I don't know where my team is!
Fuzz, you're behind you.
Is that my team?
Yeah.
Ohhhhhhh!
Oh no!
Oh, one guy fell.
One guy fell.
Okay, okay.
I can't see shit!
I'm stuck!
Guys, I don't know where to go!
I can't see over there.
Help!
There's too many people!
Guys!
Am I doing anything?
I don't think I can get up here.
What the heck?
Okay.
I don't know where to go from here.
This is stressful!
Guys, it's over.
Why are you not swimming?
Why are we on the top of the mountain?
It's so over.
I can't see.
Hi, Shane.
Shane, are you in F5 right now?
Yeah, I'm in F5.
What's going on?
Guys, I can't see anything.
Please get out of my face.
Oh, I can't see!
Open his mouth.
Guys, I don't know... Oh, wait!
It's in front of me!
I don't see you!
But I think you're near me.
I see steps.
Just keep communicating with me.
Go under!
Where is it?
I'm so confused!
Oh!
He's dead!
I saw somebody die!
Oh, my God!
Oh, F5, you're right!
Wait!
No, I can't!
Because I don't know where to look at!
Oh, my God!
He's a dead guy!
Oh, they're so many dead people!
It's okay.
If I don't look behind me...
If I don't look behind me, everything will be fine!
Okay.
We're recharging.
It's fine!
Everything is fine!
Okay!
Okay, we're fine!
We're fine!
There's no way!
There's no way we're at the bottom!
Why?
Why are you guys doing this?
Oh my god, the first save zone!
We made it!
Oh, that's the save zone!
Okay!
Okay, I didn't like that sound.
That sound was a little scary.
It was a little sus.
Oh, we're on the save zone, so we all have to wait!
We all have to wait!
I think I got some kind of a laugh.
Oh my god, nice!
We made it!
It might have been really fucked up, but we lived!
Oh my god, nice!
Oh my god, thank you!
Oh my god, I feel... Oh my god, thank you!
Finally!
Oh my god!
Oh, everything is nice and quiet!
Quiet now.
We took our beds.
Oh thank god we took our beds.
The voices are gone.
I did it!
I couldn't see what was going on!
I have to F5!
Wait, she...
Did you F5?
I did it!
That was fucked up.
Remember that first obstacle with the trees?
That shit was crazy.
I don't even know how we got there.
I think we got TP'd.
Oh my god, E-Rob, you made it!
Yeah, yeah!
Were you like 107th or something?
Oh my god, we did it guys!
Yo, we barely made it.
Oh my god.
We did it!
We did it for us!
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
Did you see this?
Oh!
I took my meds.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
Silence.
The voices are gone.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god.
Oh my god.
Guys, remember to take your meds or you're gonna have to listen to that the whole time.
Oh.
Remember to take your meds, guys!
Take your meds!
Alright.
We have two more checkpoints.
I think we can make it.
We weren't in the back of the pack, chat.
Like, we weren't...
I think the moment I get hit by the monster, I'm fucked.
I think that's really it.
The moment the monster fucking touches me, like, it's over.
Like, it's so over.
We just shouldn't let the monsters touch me.
And we should be good.
Oh!
I feel like...
I feel like people don't revive because like...
It's just so chaotic.
There's no way.
Oh yeah, the parkour is gonna be crazy.
The people who don't have the F5 is gonna get fucked over.
Because I could not see.
I could not see in first person.
At all.
Everyone's just running.
Remember to conserve your stamina.
Yeah, I need to remember to do that too.
Oh wait, it's time.
We gotta get there.
It's okay, we have peace and quiet.
I can't wait for more people.
I feel like we should be eliminating more people.
It's just...
108 is still too many people.
It's still too many.
We need to get rid of some.
Yeah, this was not meant for this many people.
I feel like maybe have people each have their own parkour area.
Like maybe divide it by 30.
And then we have like 30 of these.
And then we have like multiple...
multiple parkour areas.
And have 30 people in each.
I feel like that would have been better.
Yeah.
It's just... yeah multiple lobbies.
This is just too much.
This actually is too much.
I mean I can not...
I can't even see where I am right now.
Like...
Guys, I don't know if I should play in F5.
I can't see where my body is.
Where am I?
I'm like in the...
I've been like in the...
Holy shit!
The game almost crashed.
I'm like in the fucking club.
Oh...
Oh!
Where am I?
Guys...
Guys, I'm not gonna...
I don't...
Guys, I think this was a mistake.
Guys...
This seems to be a mistake now.
Oh no.
Guys, I think it's over.
Guys, I'm doing worse.
I'm actually doing worse.
Oh no.
I'm doing worse guys.
Oh no!
Oh no, this is bad.
Okay, we gotta...
We gotta do this.
I'm actually doing worse now.
We got it on F5 everybody.
I can't see.
I actually couldn't see guys.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Don't worry, it's not over yet.
We just gotta have to make it to the second checkpoint everybody.
The moment we make it to the second checkpoint, we'll be okay.
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh yeah, that was definitely a mistake.
Whoever said F5, that was a mistake.
Now we're fucked a little.
Now we're a little fucked guys.
Okay.
I don't know how to like...
make it so that...
Guys, how do you make it so I don't use my stamina accidentally?
Because it won't let me cancel it.
I feel like...
I feel like I can't cancel it.
Oh, I got the one of the...
No, no, no.
Oh no.
Do we have to do this again?
We do.
No, my stamina!
Okay.
We're okay.
No!
We're not okay!
Slow and steady.
Slow and steady, Doki.
It's parkour!
There's people worse than you at parkour!
No.
Oh god.
There's people back there...
that's worse than you at this.
It'll be fine.
Oh god.
There's people that are so cocky...
when it comes to...
parkour!
Okay, nice.
You got this!
Do I?
Oh no.
Oh my god.
My stamina.
Okay.
Oh, there he is.
Oh god.
Oh, I'm so fucked.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
Woo!
Behind me!
Is he behind me?
I don't wanna look!
Oh god.
Fuck!
Oh, that's scary.
That was so scary.
Oh!
We're okay, we're okay, we're okay, we're okay, we're okay.
That was really scary.
But we're okay.
Oh my god.
I just saw somebody die in front of me.
Oh.
Shit.
Oh god.
Like...
It's so scary, cause like...
Oh, my hands are shaking.
I hate parkour.
Oh, guys!
This is so bad!
Cause my hands are actually shaking!
Oh god.
Oh!
Okay.
We gotta recharge our stamina.
Oh god.
Oh!
My hands are shaking so much!
Oh god.
Woo!
I have to...
I'm so nervous, so I have to like...
Do it one by one.
Cause I'm so nervous.
Cause my hands are shaking so much.
Parkour makes me so nervous.
Okay.
Everything is okay.
Woo!
Oh!
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh god, I thought I couldn't see.
I couldn't see right there.
Oh.
Because like, there's no way!
They just have to eliminate two, right?
There's no way I'm the last two!
I only messed up the parkour like once!
Oh, I can't see.
Why is this so long?
Why was the first one so short?!
Like...
Okay, this is bullshit.
The first one was so short.
And this feels like a...
The fucking level gap between the two.
Ugh.
Alright, here you go.
Please, I'd rather be average.
Let me be the middle of the pack.
Oh, thank god there's at least two people behind me.
Thank god.
There's at least...
Because there's at least two people behind me.
We should be fine.
Woo!
Oh my god, the fact that no one's at the safe zone yet.
It's concerning me.
Look at this.
No one's at the safe zone!
There's still like 200 fucking parkour!
It never ends.
It never fucking...
It's like the marathon all over.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
I hope I have allies.
I...
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Okay.
We have a conservative stamina here.
I'm gonna go back to the safe zone.
Oh god, oh god.
Oh god.
I'm going left, I'm going left.
It was too scary, so I'm gonna go left.
Oh.
I hope left is okay, because I only have one person I'm following.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
I'm a little worried.
That there was only...
one person that was there.
Okay.
Oh, I'm getting better.
Wait.
Oh god.
Someone made it.
That means there's an end.
Oh my god.
People are making it.
That means there is an ending to this.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
No!
Checkpoint's not that bad.
Okay.
I didn't fuck up too much.
I got scared there.
Oh god, here we go.
Okay.
Almost scared myself there.
I've refilled that stamina!
Oh.
Okay.
But...
There is an ending chat!
Oh my god.
The fact that there is an ending...
gives me so much hope!
Oh my god.
There is an end...
to this madness.
Oh my god.
Oh, I don't like that...
numbers are going up.
Oh no.
I don't like that.
I don't...
Oh no.
Please help me.
I can be middle of the pack.
Please.
Let me be the middle of the pack.
That's all I ask.
Oh god.
Where is everybody?
Oh, 58.
Oh, the numbers are increasing, guys!
Guys!
Oh!
Oh.
Wait...
Is that it?
Is that the end?!
Is that it?!
Oh, I'm 70'1!
Let's fucking go!
Oh!
I made it!
Oh my god.
Oh, I made it.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, we had a very scuffed start.
We had an incredibly scuffed start, but we still lived.
The start... definitely could be improved by a lot.
Yeah, we had a very rough time there.
That was pretty fucking rough.
No more F5 chat, we've learned.
No more fucking F5 for us.
I was so stressed out.
I was so fucking stressed out there.
My hands were literally shaking.
Now they have to eliminate five more.
Oh god, I just can't be the last five.
If I live... if I... I just can't be the last five.
I didn't mess up the parkour!
So we're okay.
Oh my god.
My heart.
My heart can't take these games.
Hey, Gumi's behind me?
Where is she?
I don't see her.
You liars!
Ugh, it's fine.
I'm just happy that I was 70, so I was in the middle of the pack.
Wait, she's right there?
Where?
I have the... I have it turned off because I took my meds today.
So I don't hear the voices at the moment.
Um, you'll hear her?
Guys, I don't know.
I might hear her, but I'll also hear 30 other voices.
So I don't know.
I don't know, guys.
I don't really want to hear 30 other voices.
The dark corner.
Okay.
Dark corner?
Where?
I'm trying to like... Okay.
And then I have to like let go of W.
Okay, I'm trying to like remember how to like look at my...
I passed it?
Oh my god.
I can't find her!
Where is she?
Are you sure?
Are you guys... Did you guys take your meds?
Right of the door.
Oh, this is right.
Oh, here she is!
Hello?
Who me?
Oh, now you want to look at me, you stupid...
I could... I had it muted!
I couldn't find... I muted the voice!
I was right!
I ran in front of you twice!
I took my meds.
Sorry.
So I couldn't hear the voices anymore.
I wasn't even talking to you.
I ran in front of you.
I'm bl... You know I'm blind!
I appreciate you.
You know that!
You turned away from me twice!
Okay, I don't know about that.
I don't remember that.
Oh, I muted.
I realized I was muted.
I did.
Your chat probably does.
Okay, my... Yes, my chat was telling me where you are and I was lost.
I kept looking around.
Okay, take a break.
You're hiding in the corner!
How am I supposed to see that?
You know what?
You were running around right here.
Yeah?
You were running back and forth here.
And then you... You just turned away.
I was like, you know what?
I'm done.
I don't know!
You were in the corner!
How was I supposed to know?
Doki, what points did you get?
I got 20 first.
I... I made a mistake by having F5 and I bumped into everything.
I appreciate you.
Hey.
I was like 70 something, so I was like in the middle of the pack.
Hey, not last.
Yeah, not last.
I was alone by myself for a while.
Wait, really?
That's scary.
That's spooky.
I didn't get caught by the monsters though.
I didn't get caught either, but I went on the right path to the monster and everyone went left, so I was all alone.
Monster on the loose.
Yeah.
Yeah, that was so scary when the monsters were chasing.
The dog one was scary.
The one on all fours.
Oh yeah, that guy was huge!
Honestly, I made shatter go in front of me because I was scared.
There was a couple people waiting.
I was just like, I'm just gonna run at it.
Wait, did you... Wait, you ran at it?
How did you live?
If you have full stamina, if you just run past it, usually once it aggroes you, it won't be able to chase you for long enough.
Oh my god, it's so smart.
Minecraft tech.
It has like an area of...
Guys, why couldn't you give me that Minecraft tech?
Like if the end was like over there...
There's so many of you.
Why have you guys could have given me that advice?
One last person.
That must be so like scary.
Like...
Yeah.
Okay, no.
When everyone started coming into the game, I was like, oh my god, I'm all alone.
Who got eliminated?
Well, good to see you.
I feel like it's so embarrassing that they put your name up at the top.
Oh, Darryl, this guy got eliminated.
Oh no.
Look at those people getting eliminated.
Not us.
Sucks to be them, right?
As long as it's not us.
See that person?
I could have picked them up and I didn't.
Let's go.
High fives.
Up top.
Yeah.
Are you...
Maybe you are a bad boy.
I am.
I didn't pick up any randoms.
Wait, if it was me, would you pick me up?
Yeah, if it was you, I would.
I would be behind you.
You have to turn around.
You're all not turning around.
You're not turning around for me?
I'll pick you up.
See, okay, wait.
Yeah, I will do it.
Everyone's like, you're both me.
Well, Dokie, here's the problem.
I think all of us are usually ahead of you.
Yeah, yeah, but you'll turn around, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, you'll turn around, right?
Girl, how are you gonna...
I'm gonna call you on Discord if you don't pick me up.
I'm on Do Not Disturb at all times.
You have my phone number.
Maybe you have my phone number.
Yeah, I'll call you on your number.
It's very...
Just remember.
I'll call you on your phone number.
I'll call you on your phone number to pick me up.
This game gives me anxiety.
I hate you.
I'm gonna mute again.
There's too many voices.
Dude, just come over here.
Yeah, but the gates.
There's three minutes.
Look at the timer.
Three minutes.
But the gates.
Show mama.
Oh, whoa.
Is that nice?
Oh my god.
That parkour shit stressed me out so much.
It was so... My hands were shaking.
Oh, I just stopped sprinting after each jump and then I had full stamina the entire time.
Yeah, like, I don't believe... It was just so stressful.
Were you F5-ing the entire time?
Is that why?
No.
I was like... I was first person.
You're supposed to be playing F5.
After I played it F5 in the beginning, it was such a mess because I couldn't see where I am.
So I just played first person.
You're about to get scrambled.
I'm sorry about that.
That's what I'm saying.
I felt... I feel like this one, this next one, or the last one will have a lot more monsters.
Because I feel like this one was parkour heavy.
Yeah.
Yeah, 100%.
I'm pretty sure this one is also parkour because there was like the one with the lava in the cutscene.
We already did the lava.
No, no.
The full lava though.
There was like a lot more lava though, wasn't it?
Yeah.
I feel like we just did the one.
I feel like I didn't see the other lava area but maybe.
I am Dr. Gluon.
How many people are you eliminating for this one?
10 in total.
So they're eliminating 2 each safety round.
Oh, so this one is 2 then.
They're 2.
Yeah.
So 4 people have been eliminated already.
Oh, so there... Oh, okay.
Never mind.
6.
It might be 8 people.
8?
Guys.
Do you automatically get up if no one picks you up or are you stuck down?
I think so.
So rezzing only takes a while.
It just takes a while.
Yeah.
So we can just leave people behind then.
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You leave certain people behind.
But you'll pick me up, right?
Certain people leave behind certain people pick up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Certain people.
Yeah, leaving certain people behind.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But not us.
Certain people behind.
Not us.
If you don't pick me up, Gumi will be mad.
Alright.
Is that true, Gumi?
Gumi?
Gumi, we're a package deal.
You said we're a package deal, Gumi.
What happened?
Alright.
I think I understand what's going on now.
I'm just nodding.
I'm nodding.
Don't get betrayed by them.
I just heard something and that's all I hear.
Got it.
Don't get betrayed.
Betray.
Don't get someone that says he's betraying us, 5-1-1.
Yeah, that's the one that says he's not gonna raise us.
I'm not picking up certain people.
Wow.
Well, we know who we're not trusting.
Got it.
Don't get betrayed.
Betray.
I misheard the overhearing.
No.
They're telling me to save them.
Oh, yeah.
We should head over.
Right on.
Alright.
Now I took my meds again.
Pure silence.
It's okay.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
I see your colors.
Maybe I took the wrong meds.
Guys, I think I took the wrong one.
Where am I?
Where am I?!
Wait.
Where did that go?
I guess here?
Oh, god.
I can't see.
I'm scared.
Oh my god, where am I?
Oh my god.
I hope front was the right way to go.
That's what I hope for.
I'm not using all my stamina guys!
I'm actually learning!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, who was that?
Who was that?
Who was that guys?
Don't look behind.
If you don't turn around and look, you won't get hurt.
Guys, I can learn.
I told you guys.
I told you guys I can learn.
I figured it out guys!
I figured out how to conserve my stamina!
If I let go all the buttons, eventually I'll be able to learn.
I'll have my stamina.
Eventually I stopped guys.
I just gotta let everything go.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Oh god.
Oh, I hear people behind me!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
It's okay.
There's so many people that got caught.
I didn't even see the monster!
That was the scary part!
I didn't even see the monster there!
Yay!
Conserving my stamina.
Oh!
We're okay.
Guys, it only took two safe zones to learn how to play this game.
God, Minecraft is so easy.
A fucking game for babies.
Sorry!
Holy shit!
I think somebody died in front of me!
I think I think so!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
I'm pretty sure someone literally died in front of me!
Oh my god, that was so close!
Holy fuck, that was actually so close!
Holy shit!
Guys, I think... It's okay.
We're okay.
Watch your tone!
Don't ever call Minecraft.
I'm sorry, Minecraft's not a game for babies.
I'm so sorry.
It's a game for adults.
Clip.
For 18 plus and over.
But like not that type of...
But not that...
I'm 18!
I did it!
Oh my god!
I was ahead of coming!
Oh shit.
I was ahead of you!
That's what I'm talking about!
You did it!
Doki!
I was ahead of you!
Let's go!
No, Doki!
I've been standing here!
No, I got you!
I'm ahead of you!
No, I've been standing here!
Mama mia!
Oh my god!
I did it, guys!
We fucking did it!
We're so good!
18!
Let's go!
Oh my god!
Guys, is this what it's like to be a fucking winner?
I'm a... winner?
Not last!
Let's go!
Oh my god, guys!
Oh, Warren TV!
Yeah, fuck you!
You fucked me over yesterday!
Yeah, that's right, Warren TV!
You fucked... you lied to me yesterday!
That's called karma!
Oh my god!
I don't think I forgot about yesterday!
I'm a pro at Minecraft, dude.
There you go.
I told you karma was gonna happen.
Karma's a bitch.
Oh my god, I'm gonna wake up.
I'm gonna wake up from this nightmare.
Oh my god.
Why was this one so goddamn short compared to what we...
Like, what?
Why was this one so goddamn short?
Okay.
Alright.
Turning down master and bringing everything down.
Okay, we're gonna have to...
Uh...
Okay, we're gonna have to bring down the master volume, because we have no idea what is anything tied to.
What is the word?
Bring down the master volume.
We're like trying to figure out what is making the... like the ambient noises.
Um...
And like... what is making the ambient noises and the monsters.
So we've been trying to figure it out.
We've been turning everything down, but it's not working!
Like I don't understand.
Nothing was working!
Alright.
Okay, we're just gonna turn up the voice then.
We tried the weather, right?
Maybe.
It could be the weather actually.
Okay, we're gonna turn the weather down.
But...
Is this volume too loud when we were playing?
I couldn't tell.
Honestly.
Because like, uh, sound guy was saying that the monsters were being too loud.
So I wasn't sure.
It was fine?
Yeah, it was.
It's all over.
Yeah, it is pretty all over in the place.
Yeah.
It was immersive.
True!
True.
It was immersive.
It was so immersive.
Guys, see?
Every game we learn more about how to play this game.
We learn more and more about how to play.
We're getting better chat.
We're getting better at Minecraft.
Because Minecraft is not a baby game.
That was so fucked up.
I called...
I said somebody died in front of me the moment I called Minecraft a baby game.
That was so fucked up.
Like, I'm sorry.
I didn't mean it.
I was like, where did the monster come from?
Dude.
Yeah, Minecraft should be an eSport.
There should be a Bed Wars eSport.
The views will go up.
These are so insane.
God struck them for my sins.
God...
Okay, look, guys!
God's aim is a little bit wonky, guys.
Okay?
He's not a game...
God is not a gamer, guys.
Alright?
He sort of missed.
He just missed, okay?
But he taught me a lesson.
Now I know.
Never shit talk Minecraft.
No, next game is like a puzzle.
It's a puzzle game.
So like, as long as... chat, you gotta help me backseat this, okay guys?
Guys, you gotta... you gotta help me backseat.
Oh my god, he's still alive.
I can't believe he's still alive.
Where's Groomie?
We gotta combine our chats together.
Because if we average our chat's IQs together, it'd be like 2 brain cells.
And include Groomie and I.
Because like, Groomie and I, we add our brains together, it'd be like 0.1.
But if we add your chat and my... like her chat and my chat together, it'd be like 2.
So you guys are like 1.8.
Alright, we got... we can do this.
We can do this.
We put all our brains together, we can do this guys.
There's no way.
Alright, let's see who has... look at all these dead bodies.
Oh my god.
Look at all these... that's me, I'm still alive, bitches.
I'm still alive.
But Doki, we have no brains.
Yep, you have like 0.01%.
So you add it all together, it will be a 2.
Guys, it's a puzzle.
We know me and puzzles guys.
All you puzzle dragons who keep telling me to play a puzzle game.
This is your time to rise up.
Chat.
Literally, whenever you guys are like, Doki, please play a puzzle game.
Play like those like IQ games.
Guys, play that... play that IQ... like what was it?
The one where you have to draw lines or whatever to like solve a puzzle... solve the puzzle?
This is your chance to rise up and backseat me.
Everyone's like, Doki, play a little to the left.
Doki, play...
Doki, play a detective game.
Doki...
This is it.
This is literally your moment to shine.
I'm too lazy to do puzzles.
It's okay, we can do this.
I believe.
Like there's no way.
It's like we all work... we have... it's like each...
Some people don't even have a chat to help them, guys.
They have to use their own brains.
That's why... that's why we're working together.
We literally have chat advantage.
And like the best part is that... I'm sorry to all the Minecraft viewers.
Like it's not you guys.
Minecraft viewers that are watching me, this doesn't pertain to you.
This does not apply to you.
But what's the best part is that we're not Minecraft viewers.
Yeah, we're being lucky.
The main category is not Minecraft.
So the... so the average age of a dragoon is at least over 13.
So... we have a chance against the other Minecraft players.
So we can do it, guys.
But like if you're a Minecraft viewer and you're watching me, this doesn't apply to you.
Because you're watching me.
So your age is already like...
Gumi.
Wait, where are you, Gumi?
Oh, thanks.
Gumi?
Oh, wow.
It feels better.
Gumi?
Why did you do that?
Where's Gumi?
Am I hearing voices again?
Am I...
Am I hearing voices?
Where did Gumi go?
I think the next game is the Simon Says one.
Where is she?
Did I... did I imagine that?
You guys heard it too, right?
You guys heard it?
You guys heard that voice, right?
Did you not hear what I heard?
Guys.
Did you not hear... hear... Gumi?
No.
Oh, no.
Guys, I think I'm...
Oh, Gumi!
Gumi!
I see you running, Gumi.
I know you're there.
I know you're in front of me, Gumi.
Gumi, where are you going?
Gumi?
She's losing...
Gumi.
Gumi?
Gumi, where are you doing?
Gumi!
Why did you catch up so fast?
I did it.
I learned the Minecraft tech.
I was 18 plays.
Are you proud of me?
I am proud.
I was ahead of you.
Yeah.
Are you proud of me?
I became the master.
I am proud.
I am.
I only took you two save points.
Two save points.
We need...
We need to do puzzles.
Yeah, yeah.
So your chat and my chat can work together in solving this puzzle.
Right?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so we can backseat.
Oh, and then like, if our chat can look at...
No, no, no.
No, I already know what you're gonna say.
I mean, people are ahead of us.
The two in this room over here?
It's a joke, guys.
Guys, if you guys didn't know, that's a joke, guys.
It's a disclaimer.
Don't do it.
It's a joke, guys.
Don't do it, guys.
We're just joking.
We're gonna use our brains.
Oh, it's time now.
We're not gonna use other people's brains.
We're gonna use our brains together.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, and chat's brains.
But like, with no outside help other than that.
So I don't know what... Oh, wait, there's 20 Easter eggs now?
Wait, what?
Oh, let me find you.
I was not paying attention.
What are the other Easter eggs look like?
They're TVs again.
Wait, oh, there are more TVs?
Yeah, I found nine of them already, Doki.
Oh.
Here, there's one right here.
Oh, they added more TVs.
Oh, I wonder what we get for 20 eggs.
I got 18.
I'm at 18 as well.
I'm at 17.
What one am I missing that you're at?
I'm at 19.
Did you get the one behind the stairs?
Yeah, I got the one behind the stairs.
I live in Buckingham Palace.
Where's the others?
Wait, there's one upstairs?
Wait, wait, wait.
Do it again.
Really?
Oh, there's one upstairs.
I relationship where?
There's TVs upstairs.
Nah, this is going to be trouble.
I did not say this.
Who said this?
There's a TV in one of the bedrooms.
All right, I'm gonna have to .
I searched all six bedroom.
I didn't see one.
It's like next to a bed.
Just laugh.
Yes.
A!
There could be!
The liar route is open!
I mean, hey if there was one, then they found an egg!
No, no, no, not like that, no!
There's no reason!
There's always a reason, chat!
There's always a reason!
Jokekeeper!
I guess you can find one out here.
Yeah, I like how you knew I was lying when I talked about the bedroom TV.
Yeah.
Well, honestly I didn't even hear you, but I would have known either way.
I mean, I just found out about the TV, so yeah.
How many are there?
Oh no, it's time!
We gotta work together!
You was the only one that didn't run to the bedrooms.
It's jokekeeper time!
I can't believe it, I said that and everybody ran to the fucking...
Ran to the fucking bedroom!
That's actually fucking hilarious.
That's so funny.
What was that?
Are you out of your mind?
Oh no, they're not out of your mind.
What?
What's this?
The farm?
The farm.
Oh, we've been here!
Isn't this... to be fair...
This looks like...
Laranja!
This looks like the...
This literally looks like the fucking first map.
But where is he going?
He just ran past a familiar face.
Where did he go?
Oh!
There's pictures there!
There's a lot of pictures there!
Silence...
Oh, take a hit.
Nice.
We did it, guys.
We're free.
Guys, I'm running out of meds, guys.
I don't have health insurance, guys.
I can't keep taking them.
We're gonna run out of meds soon.
Guys, I don't want to have an addiction, guys.
Buy more.
Guys, what if I get addicted to it just like painkillers?
Guys, I don't want to be those painkillers, guys.
Hello.
Dude, I was talking about how you actually saw me.
And how rare it is.
Yeah, I saw you!
You're like a dinosaur.
You only see things that move.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
If you don't move, I don't see you.
Yeah.
That's true.
If you don't move, I don't see you.
I see via heat vision.
I look via heat vision and like movement.
So if you don't move...
Yeah, yeah.
I'm like...
I think it's the side effects from the meds I'm taking.
Every time I take it, the voices disappear.
Oh, I let my voices go.
You go wild?
Right now, the voices are going...
Wait, I don't think that's healthy.
What?
I don't think... I don't think that's healthy-kun.
And then the other one's going...
Wait,
then how do you hear... Oh!
Wait, how do you hear regular people?
If you're listening... hearing the voices.
It gets transcribed.
Like, there's a...
There's like a text-to-speech.
There's a little lag.
Yeah, subtitles underneath the music.
So while you're talking, I hear like...
Nightcore in my right ear, hamster song in my left ear.
Oh my god, you hear the... the... the Euro... the Eurovision song, Nightcore?
Yeah, Eurovision song was... You know that song is actually from Eurovision?
Yeah, I know.
I know.
That didn't even win, right?
That didn't even win Eurovision.
Oh!
Whoops.
Yeah, you guys don't know?
Rockefeller...
Yeah, Rockefeller Feet.
I honestly thought it was an American song.
I thought Rockefeller... Rockefeller was an American song.
But it's actually a Eurovision song.
And I don't think it even won Eurovision.
And the only reason why it's popular is because of Nightcore.
It's only popular because of Nightcore.
I don't know.
I was thinking about Rockefeller as in the... the Rockefeller... Rockefeller Street.
You know, the Rockefeller building in New York City.
Yeah, it was Estonia.
It was from fucking Estonia.
That's like the country I least expected Rockefeller to be from.
Because all I could think about is the Rockefeller building.
The Rockefeller building in New York City.
I don't think it's that good.
It sounds really good.
Seriously.
I think it's good.
She was second to last in Eurovision?
Oh my god, Rockefeller was second to last?
To be fair, that song...
That song is like the most popular song during that year too.
I didn't know that.
I thought it'd be at least popular than that.
Like who the fuck won Eurovision during that time?
To be fair.
Alright, I think everybody knows Eurovision is sort of like...
It's not really about the song.
To be fair.
Eurovision has never really been about the song.
The quality of the song.
It's about...
It's about knowing which country is your ally.
Like...
Flash me, push us off.
Dude, that's really it.
It's like I'm friends with that country.
I don't care how shitty your song is, but you're my friend.
It's just like...
It's just to show you guys who's friends with who.
Oh, I'm missing strategy talks?
Oh shit!
I was jumping around.
Wait, where's Goomy's...
Music.
Fucking cranes.
Mew, Mew, Mew for me.
Okay, Mew for me is not a strategy talk.
That's all I'm saying guys.
I don't know...
Hahaha!
Oh?
Uh oh.
We're out of the basement guys.
What?
Even the cows on the farm are all part of a fake set which the conjurer oversees personally.
You will be given basic instructions to complete tasks like baking cakes and brewing simple potions.
Guys, this is not a puzzle.
Once everyone has completed the challenge, the curse will be cast upon the last person to successfully finish the previous challenge.
In this challenge, your goal is to avoid being infected by the conjurer's...
The puzzle, bake a cake.
...for the duration of the two minute timer.
You can pass the curse to other players by tagging them.
If you are infected when the timer hits zero, your soul will forever belong to us.
The last set of players to complete each task...
...will be eliminated.
Oh god, that's gonna be me guys.
That's gonna be me!
Task 1.
The last player will be eliminated.
That's gonna be me!
Task 2.
The last player will be eliminated.
Oh god, this is gonna be me.
Task 3.
The last two players will be eliminated.
Goodbye guys, we had a good run.
Task 4.
The last three players will be eliminated.
What?
It's gonna be me!
And for tasks 5 and 6...
What the fuck?
Yeah, the hell?
Goodbye everybody.
That's a lot of people.
What happened from like 10 to like fucking 200?
Today.
So, do as the conjurer says.
And do it fast.
Or your soul shall join the house of nightmares.
Yeah, this is...
We had a good run.
You know what?
We had such a good run.
That run.
I mean, we made it this far.
Nobody expected me to be...
To last round 3.
Guys, nobody expected it.
Wait, where's my team to strategize?
Oh!
No, no, no.
Sound baited.
We did it.
I was watching other people run.
They knew where other players were.
It did look like there's...
Well, did it?
It kinda looks like there's teams, right?
I'm integrating into...
I don't know.
Wait, I actually...
Yeah.
Are they gonna divide us randomly?
I don't think so.
Or do it like they did yesterday?
I think everyone has the same map.
Yeah.
It's 15 eliminations from...
I don't think they know I just got here.
And then 5 eliminations from the curse.
So we just need to all be together.
And like...
Wait, okay.
Honestly, once we finish the task...
I would get away from it and go hide somewhere and see if anyone's there.
Yes.
Once you do it, it kinda goes task by task, right?
You do the task and then someone gets eliminated.
You do it, then we run.
I believe so.
If it is separate groups, I don't think it would be.
I think it will be.
No, that's too many people.
It was like 1, 1, 2, 3, 4, 4.
Only eliminate 20 people?
That's way too many to be split up.
Cause it's like 15 per group at that point.
Well, one in...
I think it's gonna be one in five for each group gets eliminated.
So if they do 4, then it's like, you know, it's like, you know, it's like, you know, it's like five teams, a ton of people will get eliminated.
Guys, how do I make a cake in Minecraft?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, they said.
And then like task 6, it was like...
We're gonna be, we're gonna be doing potions.
No, that's what I mean.
That's why I think they're going to do batches of teams, right?
Oh, sorry.
How do I do it?
For potions, all you do is you do nether wart, and then you do whatever you need to I think the recipe will be there cause there's no way they're gonna.
Yeah.
Guys, how do I make potions?
Cause I've never made a potion before.
How do you...
So whoever gets the slowest gets eliminated and then the next valid person that would be last to finish is gonna get the curse.
So you just get out as soon as you're done.
So you make your teams and then you compete against your team again?
I don't think it's the same.
I think it's everybody on the same map.
Is everyone on the same map?
It's 100% everyone on the same map.
8 year olds rise up!
We need you to help me make a cake and improve potions.
It is a lot.
That's really overwhelming.
That's so long.
Now is the time to take a shot to eliminate this.
Go grab the curse.
I thought you were gonna say take a shot.
That's crazy.
Alexa!
How do you make a cake in Minecraft?
So is it better to be with friends or not with friends?
If I somehow get the curse, can you let me tag you so I can chase someone?
In theory, none of us should be cursed.
Can I tag you so you can tag him?
No.
What happened to our package deal?
What the?
Did everybody play hot potato?
Yes.
There will be one person out of 100.
So you just gotta be lucky.
At that point, you just gotta get away from the last people.
I don't know if there's a delay in passing it.
I think there's not a delay.
In theory, a sweat won't have the potato.
And if they do, something terribly wrong happens.
Yeah, they're gonna wait until the last second and punch someone.
You should probably walk over to the entrance.
Is this the entrance over here?
It's set like 10 minutes.
Oh, 2 minutes.
I'm scared, guys.
We at the bottom, one egg with two sugar on each side for the milk.
And three buns, guys.
The moment we get the cake, I need you guys to spam that.
I need you guys to spam that.
So when you have the stuff for the cake, you can just...
There's no emote only.
There's no emote only for today.
Good luck, guys.
Good luck.
Okay, so you open your inventory and you see where your shield would go, like your all-pand.
So slightly to the right of that, you click.
And does it open your crafting menu?
Yeah?
We have a crafting menu?
You'll find it.
Yeah, click a little bit to the right of where your all-pand is in your inventory.
How do I...
How do we open our inventory?
You see at the top left, there's like a red X next to the thing on the right.
How did he open...
Oh my god!
You wanna click that, and so it says showing craftable with the checkmark.
And then once you get the stuff for a cake, it'll tell you how to...
It'll like literally just...
You just click on it and it'll make it for you.
Yeah, then you can just click it.
We need to walk over there.
Wait, what did he teach us?
I forgot!
I had to put Minecraft in so long!
How can you forget?
It's been so long!
Where are you?
I don't know, but people got eliminated.
A Minecraft player got eliminated.
Oh, he did.
I know.
First date.
You gotta follow my voice, Fulham.
No, no, I wanna hear it louder.
Louder, louder.
Hello, Fulham.
Right click on the shield?
There's nothing on the shield.
Stop meowing, you perv.
Stop it.
Oh...
Oh god.
Where's my tag?
Find fuel at the fuel power...
...
...or the generator?
I hope these guys are heading to the generator.
...
Wait, did I...
Near the farmer's house.
Oh, okay, I got confused.
I got confused.
Everybody was clicking.
Oh, E-Rap didn't bring...
...
Oh, I run.
I'm
confused.
Everything was so...
...confusing.
...
Oh my god.
We gotta run.
We gotta hide.
Run!
Oh my god.
People are trying to camouflage.
I like how people are...
We're trying to camouflage right now.
Oh my god, there's still like three people that haven't...
What the fuck?
The fuck is that?
Okay.
Alright.
How is there still like three people that haven't done...
There's still like three people that haven't done the thing.
I like this spot.
Yeah!
There's no way they can't parkour this.
Oh wait, hold on.
Up there.
Hold on.
Yeah, wait a minute.
Hold on!
Yo, yeah, shift back here for the tag section.
Look out!
They won't find us really, surely.
Wait.
We're fine, we're fine guys.
We're fine.
No!
No, I wanted to...
It's a bit of alarming that Feinberg and Fairfire left.
Oh, who is it?
Someone got eliminated.
I'm eliminated.
Hang tight until the next one begins.
No way.
This is such a good hiding spot.
Good job.
Oh, I see them over there.
They're...
Oh, oh, whoa!
Whoa!
What the fuck?
La TNT.
Oh, I know.
Oh, what?
Oh.
Run!
Oh, god.
Where are we running?
They're over there.
Isn't that behind us?
Run!
Okay, there's the one.
Get it on its front.
Let's see.
I don't know where she is.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
I don't know.
I don't know where they are.
I hope he died.
Yo, guys, I take you to like dark...
Are they behind me?
I can't tell.
I'm so scared.
They're behind me.
I'm just going to keep running because I don't know.
Like I said, like I said, I have a bad idea.
There's no stairs?
No, no way I'm here.
Wait, can we see the motherfucking through walls?
Yeah, yeah, we'll see them.
We'll see them through walls.
It's not...
Everybody's silent.
Wait, do we see them?
I'm scared.
I haven't seen them at all.
Where are they?
I can't tell.
Wait, do the motherfuckers with COVID faster than us?
No, no, no.
Shh.
Ryan, you're cracked.
I'm cracked.
Well, yeah, you're awesome.
I am very much cracked.
Probably shouldn't hide in the house.
Shh.
He's coming here.
Everybody's in the house.
They're all in the house.
Come in the house.
Are we online?
Yo, Corey Wayne.
Corey Wayne, what are you doing, bro?
Come, come, come, come, come, come.
I hope so.
Are they...
Aren't they glowing purple?
Or something like that?
I think we can see them through the walls.
Is it like an outline or what kind of glow is it?
They're really fine.
Yeah, it's an outline.
Here.
And why don't we see them?
False, come up here.
I hear a heartbeat.
Or does everybody hear that?
Yeah, it's getting like...
I hear a bustle.
Oh.
I wonder if it's...
Ah, there's the ladders.
I'm scared.
Guys.
Guapo, where'd you go?
Guapo, guapo, guapo, guapo.
I'm scared.
Show it to me, show it to me, show it to me.
Okay.
How?
How do you get up there?
Shift, shift, shift, shift, shift, shift.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Guapo, Guapo, Guapo, Guapo, Guapo.
Thank God I speak Spanish.
Come, come, come here.
They're saying they're coming.
Just show us, just show us.
Hide, hide, hide.
Shift, shift, shift, shift, shift.
Are you serious?
Map door.
Woo!
Let's go.
That was not the...
Wolfie.
Oh my god!
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Collect water from the crate near the water well.
Collect the water well.
Okay, water well.
Where's the water well?
Yeah, where is the water well?
Where's the wawa?
I don't know.
Wawa.
Where's the water well?
Oh no.
Oh wait, that's a well right there.
Inside the house, inside of the fridge.
Inside the fridge.
I don't trust you man.
In the farm, in the farm, in the farm.
I'm gonna keep it real with you.
I'm gonna keep it at buck fifty.
I do not trust you.
Where's the sugar cane?
Wait, it's in the house guys.
Go get it.
I'm sick.
Uh, collect sugar...
Wait, actually where's the sugar cane?
Oh, this is the water.
Where is it?
I'm so scared.
I don't know.
Is that sugar cane over there?
Oh my god, please tell me that it is.
What if the sugar is coming from like a...
Please tell me that it is.
I'm just following the crowd.
Where's the water?
Oh, I got it.
You can just grab it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where's the nether wart farm?
Where's the nether wart?
Oh, I see.
I see the nether wart.
Yeah, where's the nether wart?
Where's the nether wart?
Oh yeah, that's this way.
Where are we going?
How do we get it?
Left hand.
Oh, it's this way?
Okay.
It's by the fuel tower.
Oh, it's over there.
How do I grab the sugar?
Don't go in here.
Oh, the nether wart followed the crowd.
Huh?
Oh, it's over there.
Guys, where's nether wart?
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Where's the nether wart?
In the house.
Go to the house.
Where'd you guys get the water?
Oh, I'm so screwed.
Where'd you get the water?
Please?
Yay!
Wait, where's the water?
From the cabinet.
I'm just gonna follow.
I'm gonna follow.
Yeah, I'm gonna follow.
Are you going to the powder?
Yes, I am going to the powder.
Okay.
Okay, I follow you.
The door that leads to the middle of it.
I don't know where the water is.
Where's the water?
I don't know.
Oh, where's Clutch?
He doesn't have water.
Yeah, where's the cabinet?
Over here.
Oh.
Gumi, where are you?
Guys, where's the cabinet?
Guys.
I don't know.
Chicken coop.
Where's the water?
To go there.
We're in awkward potions.
Go to the barn.
The barn.
Chicken coop.
Oh, I didn't know it said that.
Wait, was that a chicken coop over there?
Yeah, the...
Yeah, I'm pretty sure the barn is chicken.
Gumi, are you going to brood the chicken coop?
There's chicken coop.
Where is the chicken coop?
It's over there.
Where's the chicken coop?
Oh, where's the chickens?
national numbers In the house?
Is it in the house?
No, I think it's in the house, right?
I feel like it is.
Where's the chicken coop?
Blazes Energy!
Where's the water?
I don't know where the chicken coop is.
There's something smaller.
I don't know how to get the water.
Where's the chicken coop?
Never wind up.
I'm going to throw the water.
Guys, where is the chicken coop?
It's the house of the farmer, not the farm.
Is that it?
That's the chicken coop?
That's where everybody is?
That's where all the chickens are?
Sugar first!
No, no, no, sugar first.
How do I prove it?
Sugar first!
Do not put sugar first!
Guys, wait, what?
Really?
Where is the conger?
What the fuck is a conger?
Lays top left?
And then what?
And then I put sugar?
What happens after the sweet punch?
Go to the conger.
What's that?
Wait, fire in the middle of the mix?
Okay.
And then I put sugar?
What do I do?
Get your mind out of here!
No, no, no, it's just for the sugar.
It's just for the sugar.
No!
Where is the conger?
Okay, we have to get another bottle of water, Flex.
No, no, no, I already have the speed.
Oh, God.
Where is the conger?
This big guy right here?
The one to the left.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, big guy.
Yes!
Yeah!
I lived!
Oh my God, it was so stressful!
From the other ward to the other side.
Did you guys miss?
It's fine.
When we were getting the other ward, someone was getting water.
So we're fine.
Wait, where's milk?
Where is milk?
Oh, that was so stressful.
There's gonna be cake next to...
I see a cow right there.
Yeah, there's a cow right there.
Guys, I feel like I'm gonna...
I feel like I'm gonna die from the curse.
I think I'm gonna die from the curse.
Yeah.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Eggs over there, and then sugar over there.
Eggs over there, sugar there.
Wheat there, milk there.
Where's the cow?
It's in the farm.
Maybe we should stand right next to him while everyone's getting their stuff, no?
Well, I feel like we should...
Well, nonetheless, standing here is good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is where everything is.
Every mob that's around is there for a reason, so I kinda wanna just take one of them.
Like, what is that right there?
Your objective.
Is that a cow?
Yeah, there's a cow over there.
Is that a sheep?
No, that's a sheep.
Where's the wheat?
How do we get into the wheat?
There's a door over there.
Maybe it's my turn.
Yeah?
Yeah, let's look at it together.
Yeah, let's look at the entrances.
This one over here looks like it's gonna be...
An archery test.
FPS.
I think it's gonna be good if we like...
Oh, this is bad.
I don't know how to do archery in Minecraft.
Just imagine triple take.
There's a bullet drop off.
Okay.
Follow, follow, follow.
Bro, are you just fucking with me?
I'm high rolling standing by the chest over there.
This is the cow.
We gotta get the wheat.
Wait, that's not a real cow.
It's a human.
I feel like you just followed me.
Yeah, I just wanna know where it is though.
No, look at his face!
That's not a real cow.
That can't be a cow.
I don't know.
Yeah, but he could be like a costume.
Wait.
Wait, these are all freaks.
There's no way.
There's like a head.
There's no way that's a cow.
It looks like a human cow.
It looks like some homunculus shit.
Wait, is a sheep also like that?
I don't know.
Hey, don't judge.
What the fuck?
They all have those eyes.
Those creepy eyes.
The mad cow bear.
They all have those eyes.
What the fuck is wrong with her?
What is wrong?
They all look like they have PTSD.
No, it's not her.
They all look like they have PTSD or some shit.
Oh, that's insane.
What?
You got a parkour legend here.
How do we even get up there?
Oh my god.
They just look like they are traumatized about something.
They look like they've seen things.
Yeah, just like...
Don't put sugar first!
Oh my god.
I feel like some people got fucked over because they put sugar first.
Holy shit.
God, I'm nervous.
Being alive?
I don't know.
I don't know if it's good to be like...
to live past this right now.
For the objective.
Because I'm getting more stressed the more...
the more tasks we get.
I'm getting more stressed out.
If I was eliminated...
I could be chilling right now.
Holy shit.
I'm actually so scared.
That's okay.
We're gonna be transported when the curse starts.
When the curse starts, we're gonna be transported.
So it doesn't matter.
Get out of the fields.
I'm out.
Oh, there's like cows here too.
We're gonna have to find the bucket.
Nice kill.
You know damn well that 70k is going to a fucking minecrafter.
Guys.
You know that, chat.
There's no way a regular person is gonna get that 70k.
Minecrafters have been playing Minecraft games for years.
It's been 20...
It's been almost 20 years since Minecraft came out.
Some of these Minecraft streamers have been streaming Minecraft since it came out.
Guys.
Loser talk.
Yeah, Surefour, why aren't you in here?
That was 70k.
That could have been an easy 70k for you, Surefour.
Why aren't you here?
150 people?
Guys.
Oof.
That's an oofer.
Right there, Surefour.
I can't believe it.
They asked SK.
And they didn't ask you?
Hahaha.
Sleepy and Warren were...
Sleepy, Warren, and Mendo were here, man.
Is it like... No, it's individual.
It's like an individual shit.
It's okay.
Sleepy, Warren...
All the Overwatch players got eliminated.
By the way, though.
Oh yeah.
Every Overwatch player that got in got eliminated, man.
You could have been the one that lived.
...
You could have been the last remaining Overwatch player.
What's in this room?
Oh no.
How awful.
That could have been you.
Oh yeah.
We should...
We should be in the middle.
Oh yeah.
We gotta be in the middle.
Time out.
I forgot about that.
That's why you guys wanted me to be out of the fields.
...
Oh my god.
E-Rub was 96?
...
Yeah.
I forgot.
I need to be all the way over there.
... Oh, this is scary.
Please.
Please, 97.
Give me a...
Give me a sec to join the...
the crowd.
Let me...
Guys, I'm lost!
No!
Oh no!
I'm fucked!
Oh!
Guys!
I fucked myself over.
No.
No!
I fucked myself over!
I'm not with the crowd!
Guys, I don't know how to get out of here!
...
Oh no.
Oh no, guys.
Oh, there's the crowd!
There's the crowd!
...
Oh, he's behind us!
Oh god.
I see him.
I'm going this way.
I see them.
...
It's so over.
I didn't know where I was.
...
This is an insane spot, bro.
It's gonna be so busted next time.
...
Oh, it's coming!
I'm joking, joking.
Why do you guys think this is funny?
Shh,
shh.
Shh.
Guys, I heard shift and I was like, oh, shift?
And they were like, don't shift?
And I was like, shift!
Don't move, don't move.
No, no, no.
Don't move.
Go, go, go.
No, no, no.
Don't worry, the Spanish Minecrafters know what they're doing.
The Spanish Minecrafters know what they're doing.
No, no, no.
No.
Of course they do.
Minecraft is very popular over there.
Look at Quackity.
Freddy, come with us, Freddy.
The fucking head!
Come with us, Freddy.
Freddy Pusper.
Oh, he's behind you!
Oh, he's right behind me, is he?
Nice.
We did it!
Oh, we did it.
Oh, God.
Find a note at the farmer's house.
Oh, my God.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Goomy, where's the farm?
Goomy!
Goomy, I'm right behind you!
Oh, Goomy's not slowing down, guys.
Goomy!
No, it's probably...
Because Goomy's not slowing down for me.
I'm an alien.
Wrong house!
Dude, I got so bad spawn.
That was such a bot spawn.
Wait.
Go to the fuel tower.
Wait, is it the right house?
Fuel tower, they said fuel tower.
Is that not the right house?
Yeah, they're trolling.
Wait, who's in the right house?
Oh!
Oh, doggy run!
I'm running, I didn't know!
I trusted you!
Is he in the house?
Oh my god, we were just at the bottom.
That's so cool.
Wait, where is it?
I don't know.
Desk?
Over here?
Wait, where's the desk?
Goomy, goomy, goomy, goomy!
Wait, where is it?
Oh, I got it!
I got it!
Oh my god!
We got trolled so...
We got trolled so hard, Goomy!
Oh, this is bad.
We got trolled!
Alright, back to it.
I've seen the chest, I've seen the chest!
I'm just gonna follow Goomy.
Oh no, we have to...
We saw it too!
Oh my god!
This is so nerve-wracking!
Literally one guy!
I got so confused!
That's so fucked up.
Alright, going upstairs.
Where's the chest?
It's upstairs.
Yeah, there's a pile of books upstairs.
It's so hard to speak Spanish so they don't understand.
Where's the chest?
Oh wait, no, it's this chest.
It's this, it's this.
It's behind me.
I followed Goomy!
I got confused!
Never follow Goomy!
I'm so confused!
Use a note to find a chest.
Try 1993.
Oh, is it the number on your file?
1... 1...
1... 9... 3...
Wait...
I'm not in?
Where do I take it?
Find the note right here.
Right there.
1993.
The code is 1993.
The books are at the top of the barn, okay?
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
The chest is behind the barn.
Oh god.
Oh, I got panicked, guys!
I panicked!
I panicked, everybody!
I couldn't read because I was panicking!
Did you get the note?
Run, run, run!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Find a note near the pile of books.
Where's the note?
Is that it?
We're good?
I don't know where to go.
Up here?
There's gonna be...
Books right here?
Do we have to fight right now?
Nice.
Where's the book?
I'm so stressed out!
Holy fuck!
I'm so...
I'm so stressful!
Oh my god!
Use your note!
I'm clicking it with the note!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna practice!
Haha!
Yo, you guys wanna do entry practice right now?
Oh my god!
I'm gonna practice, guys!
Oh god, there's falloff.
Which one's my arrow?
For the silverfish, right?
Silverfish is one of the bombs.
Okay.
We got aim high.
I don't even know which one's mine.
Yeah, I'm just gonna go to the middle.
There's no point in winning.
Oh, it's for practice.
I see.
I wish I was better with the bow.
Yes!
What are we gonna use the sword for?
Goomy went the wrong way several times.
I couldn't trust her anymore.
I couldn't trust her.
She went the wrong way several times.
Sonic got eliminated!
Haha!
Sonic Fox got eliminated.
You're good with swords.
One in each side.
Uh oh.
Fuck!
Deal!
I'm going this way.
I'm going to the house.
I don't know.
I'm scared.
I'm going to the house.
They are coming this way.
Which way are they coming over?
I'm so scared.
Oh no.
Guys, goodbye everybody.
Goodbye everyone.
This might be where we die.
No!
Okay.
Oh no.
Oh fucking no.
Oh no guys.
This is it.
We actually got hit.
Oh no.
Yes.
This is it guys.
It was so nice playing with you guys.
I'm so sorry.
Okay guys.
We are going to get eliminated by the curse!
To the gate.
To the GATE.
Where am I going to make it?
Where are we going to make it to the gate?
Where'm I going to make it?
Where'm I gonna make it?
Which way am I going to make it?
We might make it?
I was there at the gate!
I was the gate person!
Stay here, stay here, stay here.
Get away, get away, get away.
Look at my mind.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
Run, run, run.
Dude, they tried to get me.
They tried to get me off this top.
Oh, god.
I knew it was going to start with the bomb.
I knew it.
I'm behind.
I'm behind the gate.
I'm really bad.
Ah, people.
The gate, people.
Move, you fuckers.
Bro, you all need to get out of my way.
I swear to god, I'm going to freak out.
Is somebody going to match my...
I'm a freak.
Try to switch, try to switch.
Don't spam, try to switch.
Oh, my god.
Please, give me one.
This...
Give me one at least.
Oh, my god.
How many did I get?
Free fire, right?
It's a stupidity.
I'm going to get out of here.
Oh, my god.
How do you flash like that?
Bow them.
Okay.
Get out, get criticals, and kill the last one.
And that's it.
There's no problem.
I can't.
I can't see.
It's actually sun.
God!
Red, there's a bunch outside the barn.
Red, there's a ton outside.
It's very complicated to hit them.
Oh, my god.
Oh, they're outside?
Yeah, right here.
Okay, good.
Oh, my god.
I need one more.
I need one more, too.
Oh, god.
Okay.
They despawned.
This way is faster.
You can jump up from the stairs.
You can stand here and jump through here.
I'm dying to that.
Oh, no, no, no.
Where's the control?
In the middle?
How do we get there?
Break around the...
How do you guys get there?
Oh, no.
That was actually insane.
It's either the cake or the target practice.
Oh.
Oh, god.
Oh, I can't leave.
So stressful.
I hate this game.
Oh, my god.
Oh, please.
Well, if it's troll, it's fine.
Everyone, man.
Leave me.
Guys, please.
Just eliminate me.
Guys, I'm going to be the last tank.
There's no fucking way.
This is too much.
My heart.
My fucking heart, man.
My fucking heart.
I can't.
My hands are shaking.
And I'm so stressed out and I want this to be over.
I'm just gonna go here.
My heart can't take it.
My heart.
My heart can't take it, guys.
I'm assuming there's two more challenges and then one more ChrisRans probably.
How many have we done so far?
We've done four ChrisRans.
If someone could hit this double Neo, they're never getting tagged.
No, I don't think you can.
Wait.
I got it.
Wait, that's just so much better, isn't it?
Jesus Christ, I got infected as the first person, but he didn't notice I infected him back.
We're safe.
Oh my god, dude.
I'm like hungry.
Let's try to...
I can't.
Pssss.
They're so smart.
Hi.
Dead people, shh, shh, shh.
That's my shit on the beat, ho.
We're here!
Oh no, bro!
Hi!
Oh no, bro.
You don't know, bro.
Security.
Wait, is it one more, one more time?
They're in their toki.
Wait, they're getting too excited.
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
Stinky!
You're not just gonna hide here, aren't you gonna dip?
Yeah, I guess I'll just hide here then.
Weeeeeee!
I mean, that's not really that key.
Okay, if they ran in through stairs, we need to just escape again.
I'm taking the route out the back if they get off the stairs.
Tracker is just a hundred miles away.
Stinky!
And am I spine?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, surely.
Guys, if they come in, don't forget!
Internal panic.
Oh god.
Jump down there to fight them!
Yay!
We lived just to get eliminated!
We lived to get eliminated!
It's water time.
Oh my god, of course it's bucket, bro.
It's water time!
It's well and well.
Do you think the water well has the bucket?
Oh.
It says it on the top left.
Hello.
Okay, we didn't go the wrong way, so that's good.
Cow pen, where's the cow pen?
Cow pen, it's at the cow pen, at the cow pen.
Where's the cow pen?
Where the fuck is the cow pen?
It's over here, it's over here.
Cow pen.
Where is it?
No, no, it's not here.
Cow pen.
Does anyone remember?
Brown cow?
Follow the Spanish Minecrafters.
Yeah, I think we don't know where we are going.
Over there, over there.
Oh, we're going to the danger zone.
Go, go, go.
Follow...
Follow the Spanish Minecrafters!
Go, go.
Look, there are the chickens.
Guys, I can't...
Guys, how do I get to that weed faster?
Guys, I don't know how to get to the weed!
Guys, GG's guys.
It was...
It was a good run.
I don't know how to get to that weed.
I'm so...
I'm gonna go here.
Guys, GG.
It was a good run.
I don't know how to get to that weed faster.
It was a good run!
Goodbye.
Goodbye everybody.
I'm too stressed out to do jumps.
Oh, guys.
Collect an egg.
Oh, I know how to get the egg!
This way?
Oh.
No!
Guys.
I don't know the route.
Oh, no!
I forgot the egg route.
Guys!
I forgot how...
Guys, where's the eggs?
Yeah, it has to be R3 and X, right?
But next one is awesome.
Guys, where's the eggs?
There we go.
I don't know.
Where's the chicken coop?
Oh, is that the chicken coop?
Is this the chicken coop?
No?
Where's the eggs?
Farmer house, is it this way?
Oh guys, I didn't know where the eggs were.
I didn't know where the eggs were guys.
Is this where the eggs are?
Guys...
I didn't know where the eggs are.
GG's.
Guys, do you know where the eggs?
I'm confused.
Where are the eggs?
Nobody's helping!
Guys, it was a good run.
I actually don't know where the eggs are.
Guys, do you guys know where the eggs are?
Guys?
Do you guys know where the eggs are?
Yeah...
Where's the farmer's house?
I think I'm out though.
I'm fucking GG's.
Do you know where the farmer's eggs are?
Come here, over here!
I think it's over.
I got lost in the eggs.
I survived the second day.
My chat fucked me.
My chat made me lost.
And me too, I'm lost too.
We were both lost.
Right click, right click, hurry!
Ok...
We got the eggs!
We both got... chat, it's you and I!
We both got lost together!
Doki!
Yeah?
Come on, hurry, hurry, hurry!
Oh, I'm hurrying, hurrying, hurrying, I'm hurrying!
I'm so lost!
Gumi, it was a good run, Gumi.
No, come on, Doki, run!
You live on for me, Gumi!
Gumi, live on for me!
It's too late!
It's too late, Gumi!
We had a good run!
You and we just live!
Gumi!
Gumi, it's okay!
It's over, Gumi!
You have to accept the fact that it's over!
Gumi, it's over!
It's over at last!
At last!
Alright, I'm here to curse you all now!
It's time to curse!
Oh my god!
It's so cold!
Oh my god, it's time!
Yes!
Alright, it's time to be the curse, guys!
Oh my god!
Chad, we're both idiots!
We're both fucking idiots!
Oh my god!
Oh...
Never mind.
Shane, I was banking on following you this round...
Oh my god!
...and you seemed very indecisive...
We're both idiots!
...which is kind of concerning me.
Gumi actually clutched it!
Well, now you're going to my house.
You're going to my spot.
Gumi actually clutched it!
What?
No, no, no.
Trust.
The person knows, though.
So...
Trust.
Bakuno.
They're coming.
Kiken.
Kiken, are you there?
They went the other way at the start, so I don't know if they...
Yeah, they didn't even know he clutched it through the round with the chest.
Josh, how do we get out of this place?
No, no, no.
No, Cyd, no.
We have to get out of here.
Speed's over.
What are you doing, bro?
Bro, they can see you.
Bro, you have to clutch up.
That's the only way.
Where's Sylvie?
Hello?
Hi, Apple.
Chiv, chiv, chiv, chiv, chiv.
I think people discovered our spot.
What are you doing?
I'm coming, coming.
Coming.
Shhh.
Gumi, Gumi.
I'm coming.
Run.
Here.
Run here.
I don't think they're coming.
I don't think so.
Put the chair under the table.
Sorry.
It's Gumi.
Guys, pull out.
Shif, shif, shif.
Don't move, don't move, don't move.
Trying to get momentum.
Gumi, Gumi, Gumi.
Guys.
Gumi actually took me to the finish line.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Shout out to Gumi.
Gumi, shout out to Gumi for taking me all the way to the end.
So how are y'all doing?
What the?
Hola.
I'm trying to get you bullied.
You guys are both idiots, guys.
There were so many instructions that I got scared.
You know I panicked, guys.
You know I panicked.
We were both at fault.
That's all.
Except the fact that we both didn't get there.
Wait.
Toppo got considered out.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Now this is where we leave.
I got Catdazzar theme.
How is someone already finished?
I was seeing where you're blocking my shots, bro.
Give me a little space here, man.
I'm done.
I got like 12, man.
I got a 12.
Okay, you know what?
We should probably back to blocking.
Blocked in.
So good.
You can do it.
Did you do it?
What?
That's it?
Oh.
Okay.
Silky!
Silky, you can do it!
Remember, bullet drop off.
Bullet drop off.
Aim a little higher.
Okay.
Nice, Silky!
Oh, I got it!
I got it!
Oh!
No, no, no!
One more!
You got it!
I have to do another day of this.
Kumi.
Wait.
We have to do day three, Kumi.
You mean?
You're the very last person!
I hate that.
Oh my god.
I was... Kumi clutched it.
I was 85.
And then I tagged somebody instantly.
I know.
It's so hard.
Oh my god.
Kumi, you did it.
Me and my chat.
Now we play Valorant after this.
Okay, Kumi.
My heart cannot take it right now.
I'm fucking out.
I just want you to know.
I went through like the five seconds.
I think Sage is a grief there.
Oh my god.
No.
My anxiety was peaking for you.
Not just for myself.
The entire game, I didn't feel super anxious until you had...
Oh my god.
I was so lost.
I didn't know where the eggs were.
I was begging.
My crafters are so cruel.
Nobody would tell me where the eggs are.
And then sometimes they lie.
Yeah, they lie.
And then I'm like, wait, I don't believe you.
I can't believe it.
You're not allowed to swear.
But they gaslight us instead.
They gaslight us.
But we made it.
We made it.
We did it.
Is it going to be something scary?
Is something scary going to happen?
I don't know.
Guys, I don't know where the four embers are.
There's so many houses.
No, the hard part was you guys were like, stop, back, there, forward.
That was what fucked me up.
We survived another day of a nightmare.
We got to like, back, forward.
Rest in peace, Tubbo.
I was like, back, forward, front, left.
Oh my god.
Wait, I was on the main street.
I was on the main street.
Oh my god.
Well, I said my truth.
I said my truth, guys.
My truth.
I didn't study.
Please.
A barn can be a house.
I don't know.
I've never been on a farm before.
I'm a city gal.
I don't know what city gal is.
What's what?
You don't say.
Oh my god.
40 people tomorrow.
40 people get eliminated tomorrow?
40 elims tomorrow.
That's horrible.
I still need two more.
A house is a house.
Tubbo died for this.
A minecrafter died so I can live on today.
Gumi, please.
Gumi, I don't know in my heart.
It's a five stack.
A five stack?
Okay, if you get a five stack going.
I'm gonna go grab food though.
I haven't finished my food.
The last B-Tuber lives on.
I can't believe it.
A minecrafter died so I can be in day three.
I took an actual minecrafter spot.
Gumi.
Hi.
Where are the newies?
I'm not sure.
Uh...
Equivalent exchange.
I'm just happy it's over.
I'm happy.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe.
My man.
Tomorrow we go again.
Oh my god.
I'm doing my days.
I barely made it like four times.
I should not be alive.
I already was going through like the five stages of grief of getting eliminated.
I have the plot armor.
I'm the main character.
The main character plot.
Guys, guys.
How about we both agreed that we both fucked up together during that the egg part.
The egg section, we both messed up.
Okay?
As a group, we both take responsibility.
And then Gumi clutched it for me.
Gumi clutched it for us.
But we both messed up together.
Oh my god.
Okay, group picture time.
I'll give you celebrate anything.
He's gone.
Wait, who's gone?
Everyone's gone.
Everybody's gone.
Yeah, I took...
Lost Cub fan.
I was the last person.
I took a Minecrafter's place.
I don't even play this game.
I just learned E is inventory today.
That's crazy.
And Topa lost to me.
That's amazing.
Oh my gosh.
What horrifying thing to hear.
Are you monster?
Let me go.
Yay.
Are we looking at the same area?
I don't know.
Where am I supposed to look at?
I...
I hope I'm looking at the...
Whoa.
I hope I'm looking at the right area.
I don't know.
Who's the cameraman?
Two minutes?
Oh.
Okay.
No.
I have to be in front for exposure.
As the...
As the one of the last few non-Minecraft players in this lobby, I deserve to be in the front.
Who...
That's not fair.
You guys have to be mature about this.
I was mature enough to take responsibility.
But now you guys also have to be mature enough to also take responsibility.
Guys, we are mature adults here.
We should both equally take the blame.
Guys, we both equally share the blame.
But we can all agree.
Gumi clutched it for us.
Gumi saved our asses.
Who was it?
I kept on going.
Left.
Right.
Back.
Forward.
Yeah.
We did it.
It was me.
Guys, look.
I was very overwhelmed.
As the...
As the non-Minecraft player.
I am already directionally challenged, guys.
I was already very directionally challenged.
Oh, you finally relaxed.
Why does...
Guys.
Why did my urge of wanting to win overpowered my rest week?
I can't believe we made it to this point.
It doesn't matter.
We are going to get eliminated anyway.
We are just too competitive.
Oh my god.
This is the most stressful rest week of all time.
It really is.
It's actually the most stressful rest week we've had.
Each game has...
It's like...
I...
Why am I so stressed out?
Oh my god.
Guys.
We are going to call it here.
We might...
Apparently, Gumi wants to five stack Valorant.
So, we might be back after I finish eating.
And...
After we finish eating and...
Give...
Um...
I get...
Uh...
Wait.
What was I going to say?
Fuck.
Oh, sorry.
After I finish eating, we might pop up on Gumi's stream.
Um...
And so, I'm going to give her a raid.
Hey guys.
For those who are new here.
I actually stream on the YouTube.
It's less stressful over there.
Um...
It's...
It's a lot less stressful over on the YouTube side.
So, check me out there.
If you don't want...
If you don't want anxiety each game.
Because I think...
I don't know how to read.
Check me out on the YouTube.
And if you guys want to know whenever I go live on Twitch.
Uh...
Check me out on...
Like follow me on Twitter.
Uh...
So, you know whenever I'm live on Twitch guys.
Um...
And...
Uh...
What else?
If you want to support me through other means.
Please feel free to check out my merch.
Hey guys.
I can finally stop shaking.
I swear nothing has made me as anxious or stressed out.
I'm just...
Literally, butz this.
Like I don't even play Minecraft.
I don't know why.
I don't even play Minecraft.
Why is this so fucking nerve wracking?
Hey guys.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you suffer from me, head to bed.
Cuz you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!
Oh yeah.
Forgot to say thank you for all the subs, bits and files.
God.
Sorry I've been so stressed out that...
I've been so forgetful.
So, bonus ending.
Thank you for watching.
We're all the subs, biddies, and Fyans, everybody!
Anyway, bye for real.